eh bien nous sommes ici dans le patio du
musée des beaux arts à nantes je salue
en passant monsieur le conservateur où
vient d'être donné le départ du grand
jeu de la fresque en quoi consiste ce
grand jeu monsieur charrier c'est une
décoration que tous les enfants de
nantes vont effectuer au cours des
semaines qui viennent
les enfants de quel âge aux enfants de 8
à 12 ans et qui consiste à faire quoi
et bien simplement amener un élément un
élément de décoration alors sur le thème
de la terre à la lune
oui mais alors pour que ses enfants
puissent bien travailler vous les avez
un petit peu aidé au départ je crois
alors bien sûr on leur donnant quelques
idées en leur faisant visiter
l'exposition à voilà qui est important
voilà et alors toi tu t'appelles liquide
et qu'est ce que tu as l'intention de
faire saturn pour décorer la fraise de
jules verne
je crois que ils ont la possibilité de
choisir monsieur charest absolument oui
ils peuvent très bien décorée sur la
terre sur la lune dans le cosmos et toi
qu'est ce que tu préfères
j'ai fait une septième single couscous
et tu vas t'y prendre 2 de quelle façon
tu décor ça comment avec quoi et du
papier de quelle couleur
j pris vers saturne j'ai pris bleus une
couleur bleu ciel sur le fond et puis je
rie under pour faire le tour de ces
cures l'anneau sur l'anneau quel âge tu
as 10 à 11 ans bon mademoiselle vous
vous êtes élève des beaux-arts et vous
êtes chargé je crois d'aider ces enfants
à réaliser cette fresque de quelle
manière vous y prenez vous c'est bien
nous les guidons
nous leur conseillons de faire certaines
choses plutôt que d'autres oui j'entends
bien mais est ce que les enfants tout de
même quelques idées pour des pubs sont
les enfants qui décident ce qu'ils ont
envie de faire ce qu'ils veulent faire
nous les guidons simplement eu après
pour recoller ou réunir les différentes
parties de ce qu'ils ont réalisé
et alors jusqu'à présent quel genre
d'objet ont-ils coller sur cette grande
fresque qui est tim morse d'ailleurs vu
surtout c'était des fusées
des maisons mais alors nous avons eu des
fils d'après midi et les filles font
plutôt des personnages est intéressant
est ce que les filles et les garçons ont
des idées différentes
oui certainement et garçons c'est des
autos on voit qu'il était sensé par les
fusées les ballons bon et cette petite
demoiselle comment comment elle
s'appelle tu t'appelles comment comme en
irlande se reparlent bien fort n'ai pas
peur et qu'est-ce que tu es en train de
faire en ce moment est ce que tu as une
petite idée des oiseaux et l'autre
demoiselle là tu tu veux t'approcher tu
seras mignonne elle est tout à fait
minime tu t'appelles comment martin et
qu'est ce que tu as l'intention de faire
avec tous ses papiers jaunes blancs
rouges bleus ils sont de toutes les
couleurs ils sont jolis est-ce que tu as
compris le jeu de la grande fresque dix
mois un petit peu ce qu'il faut faire
elle ne sait pas elle est un petit peu
intimidé une sphère de l'herbe de de
laird et combien d'enfants sont passées
jusqu'à présent et combien vous pensez
qu'il va passer d'enfants pour réaliser
cette fresque
ce matin nous avons quatre classes de
garçons qui comprenait à peu près
chacune 30 élèves oui cet après midi je
compte nous avons eu quatre groupes
aussi 30 élèves à peu près d'ailleurs je
crois bien que ceci est le domaine de
monsieur charrier à qui nous allons
demander tout à l'heure quelques
renseignements complémentaires comme
nous les y ont tout à l'heure nous
sommes au départ de ce grand jeu
évidemment c'est à dire que les choses
ne sont pas encore prêts structurés
les petits personnages la décoration est
encore un peu vague mais tout ceci bien
sûr va prendre du relief avec le jour
avec le temps mais bien sûr oui
d'ailleurs dans la semaine qui vient le
jeudi m dimanche par exemple
l'exposition est ouverte aux enfants
individuel avec leurs parents et ils
pourront ainsi de corée la fresque
comme ils ne voudront il ya une
précision que je voudrais que vous nous
donniez voyant ceux ci c'est la grande
fresque centrale mais il y as je crois
des fresques plus petit frisson réalisés
dans plusieurs villes de france
ah oui par exemple dans 10 villes de
france nous allons avoir des fraises qui
font
m de haut sur un mètre cinquante de
large et qui sont faites par une classe
d'ailleurs d'une école d'une école de
france d'une ville
strasbourg par exemple marseille va
venir lille énormément de ville encore
est alors à la fin du jeu comme à les
choses se passeront tel tous ces gens là
vont venir à nantes
mais bien sûr ils sont reçus par la
municipalité de nantes ils vont être
reçus avec une bonne réception et il y
aura une onu pardon une inauguration ici
le 28 au matin avec un vin d'honneur et
un jus d'orange a donc bien sûr pour les
enfants
elle est tout les fresques seront
présentes ici avec la grande